gas Rick in the middle of the Norwegian
sea so quite a change of landscape that
we have today
we announced then a month ago that we
are working on a green Alliance
a green Alliance is a very ambitious
high-level climate and energy
partnership
it is only the second of its kind after
the one the European Union has with
Japan and it is the very first green
Alliance that we have with the European
country
today I'm very happy to announce that we
have concluded our green Alliance we are
opening a new era of privileged
cooperation it's privileged cooperation
on climate action privileged cooperation
on clean energy we're working on the
industrial transformation on
Environmental Protection so a lot of
topics are under the umbrella umbrella
of the green Alliance green Alliance
it will allow us to move along to the
path to climate neutrality side by side
to join forces
of course we are building on everything
we're working on together already
for example we will expand our joint
work on carbon capture and Storage
and we have work on going on clean
hydrogen and electrolyzers we are doing
this under the European clean hydrogen
Alliance
but I want to mention two points more
specifically
the first one is Renewables in
particular offshore wind
the two of us are now way to our stand
on the Belgium Coast where we'll have
the summit of the North Sea countries
for offshore wind today and this
includes of course Norway
these countries have a shared ambition
to work together and to boost offshore
wind energy production and I want to
thank you for that Jonas because of
course the wind that is harnessed by the
turbines in the North Sea will help
power Europe's cleantech industry
it will provide secure and affordable
energy to Europeans
my second point is critical raw
materials and we had just this point in
the bilateral
the very materials we need to build the
North Sea wind turbines and much more
are these critical raw materials
they are a key strand of our green
Alliance to work together on a greater
strategic autonomy in this area
because we know how important these
critical raw materials are for our green
transformation
and of course we did not wait for the
green Alliance to work on that last year
we announced that we are working on a
strategic partnership focusing on the
critical raw materials and the batteries
value chain and this work is ongoing and
we hope to finalize it soon
my last Point
um this screen aligns I think the Jonas
is also a symbol for the deep bond and
friendship between Norway and the
European Union
a friendship that is demonstrated by the
exceptional partnership that we have
formed during last year's energy crisis
the energy crisis that has been
triggered by President Putin when he cut
the supplies of pipeline gas to the
European Union
and it was a time where you immediately
stepped in and increased your deliveries
to the European Union that was crucial
for us to prevent literally blackouts in
the European Union
it is in times of need
that you get to know your true friends
and Norway showed in an exemplary manner
that we can rely on each other
today Europe still needs reliable and
affordable supplies of gas to prepare
for the next winter and the next storage
filling season I'm particularly happy
that in the years to come nor will we
maintain its high level of gas supplies
and will respond positively to the
upcoming tenders today we add a
forward-looking green chapter to our
energy corporation as we are working
together towards climate neutrality many
things for that
let me thank you and let me start by
thanking you personally because you have
been
a exemplary partner and driving force
behind this green Alliance we started to
work on that when we met
back in February last year I remember it
was two days before the attack by Russia
on Ukraine
and it's a paradox that this great
ambition has been pushed forward by that
terrible War which is waging in being
waged in Europe
because the need to accelerate the green
transition is on everybody's mind Norway
is striving to reach our climate goals
in close cooperation with our European
Partners we are integrated with the
European economy and this green Alliance
is
delivering a very comprehensive answer
on how we will do that it's an intention
of will it depends on us to follow up
with industry with our authorities with
governments and we had a lot of ambition
and enthusiasm for this so I'd like to
thank you very strongly for that when we
were in need during the pandemic for
vaccines we were able to get support
from the European Union and we will not
forget that and I'm happy that we were
able also to step up on our gas
deliveries as you said right now
so we have this strong partnership which
is now reflected I think in a very
detailed and ambitious statement with
this green Alliance I'm proud to see
that Norway is the second of the Japan
which is the third largest economy in
the world to conclude this comprehensive
agreement and we are building on as you
said sectors where we already have come
quite far
sustainable raw materials batteries
we're already moving forward but here we
will move into other very important
chapters carbon capture and storage we
had not come that far a year ago now we
have come much farther and later today I
will be with my Belgian colleague to see
how Belgium is planning for CO2 export
by pipeline which may end up being
stored under the seabed of the North Sea
as we could show you up out there at the
troll a platform a few weeks ago uh
climate and environment sustainable
management of the ocean deforestation
support to development countries as they
reach their climate ambitions glean
green Mobility
low end carbon shipping electric
vehicles stereo emission Aviation it's a
whole menu
so this menu will only taste if we
really produce tangible results and for
me this is a blueprint for creating new
jobs green jobs sustainable jobs which
will modernize our economy and put
Europe in the front and I think we have
experienced what it means to become
dependent
on countries and regimes which really
don't share our values and we will
always live in the in a world of multi
polarity and trade and and diversity
but Partners have to come together now
on this this uh this climate green
ambition and I'm very happy that we do
so with the European Union our closest
partner and I look forward to overseeing
the follow-up of the green alliance with
you and we start today so by this
afternoon we will be indoor center with
the government colleagues to really
highlight and lift one important element
of this statement which is offshore wind
where Norway has the ambition to produce
30 gigawatts of new
Renewable Power by 2040 and we are
already putting in motion the first big
steps on that track so thank you for
being such a good partner on this and I
look forward to the follow-up very
good very good
[Applause]
thank you